you know out of the kindness of my heart
I'm gonna you know start giving giving
you guys some advice so I have a story
from Reddit
here you know and and I love I love
giving the people advice so and I I
never know if they're real or not but
let's just I mean this has probably
happened to somebody right okay
I found out my girlfriend was a
prostitute
oh my God
I 32 recently found out that my 29 year
old female girlfriend has been working
for sex on and off the last nine years
my girlfriend and I have been dating for
three months and everything is great we
have great chemistry and have a lot in
common I believe she's the one I want to
marry until last weekend we went out
with the friends for drinks last
Saturday and got drunk my girlfriend
fell asleep while her friends and I
continued talking and drinking her best
friend accidentally had a tongue slip
and told me that my girlfriend had a lot
more sexual experience than me she said
my girlfriend was a stripper when she
was 20 and had sex often with clients
she did this on and off for nine years
her friend knows this because she also
worked with her I'm horrified and
disgusted
I don't know what to do
okay this is why I say women can't trust
women you see you see that chick knew
what she was doing
um you got a dump her okay this
I don't care what she says any chick
that that was doing sex work is far too
damaged to deal with uh she's gone she's
done get yourself a 21 year old keep
building yourself because this
and and this is the sad thing women are
more it's it's funny because women are
Gonna Keep like trying to hide
everything and the men are gonna keep on
coming up with devices to figure
out like internet search background it
meant when there's a will there's a way
the mineral the metal figures it out
um
yeah I think and and this is the problem
guys the problem is that
we have the like these are this is the
next generation of wives it's going
downhill this is why I tell men to date
younger this is why I say the best women
are married before 25 because what were
you doing before it's either a career
right it's either the club I don't know
what it is it's different for each chick
right
but at least you get them younger they
could spend their best years focusing on
the Family
and that's the most important thing and
that's the real problem guys is that
um
it like women women hide this stuff they
hide it really well and you know people
act like the women were just coerced
into sex work or like they felt like
they had no other choice oh no they knew
women know that McDonald's is always an
option the truth of the matter is
they're just lazy and they want
attention some women don't even do it
for the money they just want attention I
mean think about how many broke only
fans models there they're selling their
their stuff for like 5.99 and no one's
buying this is why I just say a female
promiscuity left unchecked kills and
ruins Society we're all taught the wrong
things we're all confused and we're all
just trying to figure it out and the
thing that's why I love what I do
because you know even even me like every
chick has been confused every guy has
been confused and at least we can all
come together and figure it out don't
shoot the messenger get yourself a women
shouldn't vote shirt today none of this
craziness would be going on would be
happening if women didn't vote so make
sure you get that the link is in the
description like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time